Disney World is supposed to be the happiest
and most magical place on earth and if you
ask anyone who has been, they will likely
agree.
The Disney corporation seems to be pretty
fond of it’s world famous amusement parks
as well as they are not shy to reference them
in their movies.
Some references are out in the open and other
are more cleverly woven into their film.
Here is our list of 10 Popular Disney Movies
That Cleverly Hint At Disney World!
Enjoy the video and be sure to hit the subscribe
button for more awesome content, every single
day!
Beauty & the Beast
Beauty & The Beast is one of the greatest
Disney films of all time and the world is
excited to see the Emma Watson led live action
adaption in 2017.
This movie has tons of fun references hidden
within it, but there is one sneaky nod to
Disney land that most audience members may
have missed.
When Maurice and Felipe are lost in the woods
they find a road sign with arrows pointing
in a bunch of different direction., two of
the routes on the sign read Anaheim and Valencia.
Why does this matter?
Well Anaheim is of course Where Disneyland
is and is Valencia is where California Institute
of the Arts is located and many Disney artists
come from.
It’s a quick reference and you need to be
watching closely, but it’s definitely one
that fans appreciated!
Pirates Of The Caribbean
When you think of Disney movies, your mind
probably doesn’t instantly jump to the Pirates
Of The Caribbean films, but in reality they
are some of the most successful movies Disney
has ever made.
One of the coolest things about the Pirates
franchise is that the entire world was wased
on the Disney theme park ride of the same
name, Gore Verbinski's 2003"Pirates of the
Caribbean: The Curse of the Black Pearl" put
a story behind the popular ride and turned
out to be a major blockbuster hit.
Today, the four films have combined to gross
$3.73 billion at the worldwide box office.
That total will only be going up, as the fifth
installment in the franchise will be arriving
to theaters soon.
It is pretty crazy to think that a movie based
on a silly ride would turn out to be such
a huge hit for Disney.
Tomorrowland
2015’s Tomorrowland is probably the most
“Disney” movie on this list.
The whole film is centered around a park just
like Disney World and much of the movie was
shot in the parks.
While Tomorrowland is intended to be a look
into the future of mankind’s resourcefulness,
it also made time for some fun Disney World
shout outs.
While most of Tomorrowland’s exhibits were
about scientific progress and technological
advances, it also featured references to Space
Mountain, one of Disney World’s oldest and
most famous roller coasters!
Cinderella
The Disney castle is one of the most iconic
and recognizable images in the world.
The magic castle is synonymous with the brand
so it makes sense that it is present in the
parks and films.
The real world castle is right in the center
of the park and makes for a great backdrop
for your family vacation photos.
The castle can also be seen in both the animated
and live action versions of Cinderella, where
it originated.
The goal of the Disney theme parks is to let
the public live within the magical world of
Disney and having the giant and iconic castle
present is a must.
Saving Mr. Banks
Saving Mr. Banks is a great movie that takes
a look behind the scenes of the creation of
the Disney classic Mary Poppins.
In the film, Tom Hanks took on the role of
Walt Disney himself as the story follows him
trying to convince British author P.L.
Travers, played by Emma Thompson in the film,
to allow her Mary Poppins children's books
to be made into a musical.
Saving Mr Banks actually shot a of the movie
on the Disney lot and within the Disneyland
parks.
They were able to transform the modern day
park back to its 1960’s roots with clever
set and costume design.
This is most likely the best film to have
been shot at Disneyland and is a must see
for anyone interested in the behind the magic
action that goes on at Disney.
The Haunted Mansion
The Haunted Mansion is one of the most famous
Disney attractions of all time, so famous,
that it was actually given a shot as a movie.
The film starred Eddie Murphy and was released
in 2003 alongside Pirates Of The Caribbean.
Unfortunately for The Haunted Mansion, it
did not find anywhere near the same amount
of success.
The cool thing about the movie, however, was
how much the mansion resembled the one from
Disney and audiences had a great time identifying
similarities between the two.
There have been talks about Hollywood taking
another stab at making this movie, but as
of now, nothing has been confirmed.
The Country Bears
What is your favorite Disney movie of all
time?
If you said The Country Bears, we are genuinely
shocked.
The Country Bears is a 2002 American family
musical comedy and is based on the famous
Disney attraction Country Bear Jamboree.
The attraction was a big hit at Disney, but
it didn’t seem to translate to the big screen
in any compelling way.
The film did have a few good actors in Haley
Joel Osment and Christopher Walken, but that’s
about it.
While it was a fun idea to see the attraction
re-imagined as a movie, it probably would
have been better if it just stayed part of
the park.
Mulan
People may not realize just how big a part
Disney World played in the creation of the
1998 hit movie, Mulan.
Mulan was the first animated film to be produced
primarily at the Disney animation studio at
Disney’s Hollywood Studios, which was part
of Disney World.
The idea of having people work on Disney content
from within their world was a cool one, but
unfortunately they have stopped doing it.
Two other Disney classics were also created
at this Disney World studio, Brother Bear
and Lilo and Stitch.
The studio closed down in 2004, so it doesn’t
look like we will be getting any more movies
with this particular identity any time soon.
Hercules
Hercules is the zero-to-hero story of the
son of Zeus and his adventures.
The movie is one of Disney’s bests and brought
us some of the most memorable songs of all
time.
Hercules goes from being a scrawny farm boy,
to a super jacked demon fight god all in a
few verses of song.
In the Zero to Hero song there are lots of
sneaky easter eggs such as Lion King’s Scar
as a rug, but fans may have missed the nod
to Disneyland and the Disney as a brand overall.
As Hercules rises in fame, kids are shown
to be playing with Herc dolls, drinking from
Herc cups, etc.
This self-referential moment is Disney’s
way of making fun of how they have commercialized
all of their content with the creation of
theme parks, action figures, lunch boxes and
everything else a kid could ever want!
Zootopia
Zootopia took the world by storm in 2016 and
made people remember just how good Disney
is at making fun and meaningful animated movies
that the whole family can truly enjoy.
There are a ton of Easter eggs and hidden
messages in this movie but there is one that
you have to be pretty geographically savvy
to catch.
In the movie, the design and color scheme
of the license plates of Zootopia directly
resemble the real license plates of the state
of Florida.
Why does this matter?
Well, Walt Disney World is located in Lake
Buena Vista, Florida, so this was clearly
a fun shout out and done with intention.
So there’s our list of 10 Disney movies
with cleverly hidden Disney World easter eggs
in them.
What did you think of our list?
What’s your favorite ride at Disney?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more fun videos – like this one!